I won't lie the first time I heard about
this movie's title I thought it was
about like a really expensive piece of
jewelry that's exactly what I thought it
was about The Bling Ring is directed by
Sofia Coppola and it stars Emma Watson
and a slew of very talented young
teenagers this film is about young
teenagers in real life who stole from
famous celebrities they would check the
internet to see where these various
celebrities were gonna be out of their
homes whether they were filming
somewhere at some party and then they
would literally just walk into these
celebrities homes and rob him and this
film retails these events fairly
factually I did a lot of research about
the movie after I saw it and quite a bit
of this movie including various web cam
footage and things that they actually do
show very much so Mears what actually
happened in real life and you could look
at the movie and say well it's just a
story about some teenagers who are
robbing people and the consequences of
that and it is that but it's also more
of a social commentary The Bling Ring
has a lot of things to say about how
teens are in today's day and age when
they're in school and they're unpopular
and they want to do something to make
themselves more popular and they feel
that the only way they can do that is to
have expensive things or to just not
care about society and that commentary
on today's younger generation is
definitely there and it's in the movie
and I could feel and recognize that and
sometimes the film did a great job at
exploring that and sometimes it didn't
overall I enjoyed the bling ring and I
thought that it was a film that as it
went along I became steadily more
interested in it it's extremely easy to
look at the performances in this movie
and say that they're awful because all
the teenagers basically just go like
whatever and hey homie and how you doing
dog and what's up like that's really the
majority of the dialogue in this movie
and at times that can get a little
annoying but it's really an accurate
portrayal of how kids like this act from
all the research I've done it seems the
portrayals of the actors are giving to
these characters is extremely realistic
and I have to credit the actors for that
because there are times when you watch
the movie and you're like wow these
people suck at acting but in reality
most of the actors in this movie are
going for a very minimalistic take on
their characters they're not trying to
get noticed they're not trying to be big
in a scene or look at me I'm an actor
they're just doing what kids would be
doing more than likely if a group of
girls and one young boy invaded a house
and found all these riches he'd probably
just be like oh wow this is awesome oh
look at this it's cool on me the problem
is a lot of
movie is that and it does get a little
repetitive sometimes and well the social
commentary is there in this sort of
satire on the whole is it right to steal
from celebrities because they're so rich
and is it okay just because they're so
rich and there's a specter in the film
that definitely explores that but it
does get a little annoying sometimes
when you feel like the film isn't really
going anywhere emotionally but the film
actually picked up a lot once I noticed
that the characters were starting to
deal with the consequences of these
events because in that aspect of the
film I really thought it was strong
because it seemed like that was almost
what they were going for the story Sofia
Coppola really wanted to tell was this
strange take on how kids view Fame and
how stealing from famous people affects
them and how it can make them famous or
well-known and I really could tell it
that's what she wanted to tell the first
half of the movie well interesting was a
little bit too repetitive and at times
boring for me but as the movie
progressed I did find myself more
invested in the characters and
interested aspyn fact that you don't
really know that much about these kids
the character death is really
non-existent they're really just vessels
to move the story along but the point is
that the people that these actors are
portraying more than likely didn't have
all that much depth either since they
spent most of their time doing drugs and
stealing from people so in that way I
can kind of understand why the
characters were portrayed that way it
does have issues that does have problems
it does get a little repetitive
sometimes but I would recommend seeing
it simply because it does look very good
and it's acted about as well as you
could take these characters and it's an
interesting movie and I would recommend
checking it out at some point I'm gonna
give it a b-minus
so what's your favorite Sofia Coppola
movie mine's without a doubt lost in
translation what is your guys I'd like
to know
as always guys thanks for watching and
if you've seen The Bling Ring let me
know he thought of it or if you
interested in seeing it at all it did
expand recently so yeah hope you guys
check it out if you'd like to thanks for
watching guys and if you like this you
can click right here and get stuck
menage
[Music]